and just to make this point how far into
Facebook do they actually become a
company um I don't know I think probably
I think it became a formal Delaware
company when Peter Thiel invested about
six months in when we were first talking
to Peter about raising money Dustin and
I were very clear with him that we were
planning on going back to school where I
mean our um you know I started Facebook
own as a sophomore
we took the summer offer no classes over
the summer we were working on it and
then you know our stated game plan was
to go back to school in the fall and
continue working on it them but not like
sit sit in an office and work on it
full-time and Peter was just kind of
like all right sure you are I guess he
knew better than we think he just
believed that you weren't actually going
to go back to you must have I mean you'd
have to ask him but uh I will or
interviewed him in this series I was
there you go so I I think he would
probably say that he knew that we were
not going to go back to school or
believe that he could talk us out of it
but he didn't have to it was it was
pretty clear that the amount of work was
just growing so quickly but we I
shouldn't drop out immediately
we told Harvard that we were taking one
semester off and and then we told her
every that we take another semester off
and then a year off and then after that
we kind of decided we were going back
seeing a Peter and it's sort of a
closing question what's the best piece
of advice he ever gave you I think Peter
was the person who who told me this
really pissy quote that in a world
that's changing so quickly the biggest
risk you can take is not taking any risk
and I really think that that's true
right a lot of people I think think that
you know whatever it comes to whatever
you get yourself into a position where
you have to make some some big shift in
direction or do something you know
they're always people are going to point
to the downside risks of that decision
and locally there may be right right I
mean if for any given decision that
you're going to make there's upside and
downside but in aggregate
if you are stagnant and you don't make
those changes then then I think you're
guaranteed to fail right and not not
catch up so to some degree
it's really write that over time the
biggest risk that you can take is to not
take any risks another thing that I
think Facebook is done exceptionally
well is hiring and and I always tell
founders that this is the thing you have
to get good at so how have you hired
your team and what do you look for when
you bring people on if you think about
it you know I started the company one
has 19 right so I can't institutionally
believe that experience is that
important right right or else I would
have a hard time reconciling
to myself right and and and the company
so you know we invest in in people who
we think are just really talented even
if they haven't done that thing before
and you know that applies to people who
are fresh out of university as well as
you know people like you know the CFO
who took the company public had not
taken a company public before right and
hit a lot of his background was in you
know production development to Genentech
before so you know just focus on really
talented people and so if you don't have
the experience to look for how do you
assess on the draw talent um well often
you can tell from different things that
they've done right so it's not that
obviously everyone's done something
different even if you're 19 right you've
um you've done side projects and
interesting stuff and you know I think
what's important is not to believe that
someone has to have specifically done
the job that they're going to do in
order to be able to to do it well one of
the things that I think we've done well
is is just given the people as a company
a lot of opportunity right so you know
it's not just me who started when I was
19 and and now you know I'm running this
big company there were a number of
people who joined who were you know
people I did problem sets with at
Harvard or dropped out of Stanford or
you know different programs who have
grown with the company over this long
period of time and you know one of the
things that I'm the most proud of is we
have about 12 different product groups
of the company and all of the people who
are running them with the exception of
one I did not join the company running a
product group or reporting to me that's
amazing
um and the one exception was is David
Marcus who was the CEO of 50 billion
dollar public company so you know some
pretty happy that
that he's on board and having him run a
product group I think is a pretty big
coup too but literally none of them
started off reporting to me you know
they all start off in different
different roles some where engineers
some more data analysts some more
product managers and they've all grown
but I think what happens is you know
people see that you create opportunities
for people and and that also I think
keeps the best people engaged and makes
the best people want to come work at
your company because they feel like oh
I'm going to get those kind of
opportunities too
you